i think that what happens is when
you know mother nature is kind of
bucking up
at us i think that uh um
we all kind of get put in a place where
our anxieties are magnified and
people are kind of forced to deal with
themselves in their own shadows as it
pertains to their
family dynamics and business you know
relationship dynamics
yeah it's it's been crazy to to
reconnect with self in this retrograde
period that has been
you know kovac 19 and being quarantined
amidst like civil unrest and all this
it's been it's been
absolutely crazy i i don't i don't know
i mean
is this real life is it real life i
don't know what's going on
it's wild right now i believe that each
and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense today is a very
special show with a very special new
musician
his name is eric burton and he is the
lead singer for
black blackpumas who is absolutely
blowing up they are everything from
number one on amazon
number two on itunes probably by the
time this comes out they'll be number
one
um trending on twitter uh
they performed at the presidential
inauguration
um there's just so much going on for for
this band and
um today i talked to eric and you know
i don't know much about them and i
find that it's in the inverse it's in
the conversations that
i'm not sure what to expect uh and i
don't know much about
that they kind of end up surprising me
in the most beautiful way so
eric and i had a really like a really
open vulnerable spiritual
esoteric conversation about a lot about
um you know sort of the energetics of
the world and
intention and honesty and vulnerability
and truth and um
again it wasn't so directly all about
the music tell me about making this song
it was more about how was
great music made and where does it come
from as a source
and so the interview is really really
deep um
but if you want to listen to him on the
shallow end of the pool i mean black
pumas are phenomenal their music is
beautiful and they're
and they're um they're really coming out
of the scene in a really really a big
aggressive
way and um and i know that the music
will resonate and today we're gonna talk
about
why you love it thanks for doing this
with everything you have going on my
goodness like
how was the congrats on being a part of
the inauguration how
how was that it was absolutely amazing
nothing short of
fantastic you know um obviously being a
being an american and being a musician
and and and a black man in america it
felt really nice
to uh be put in a situation where
the voice is obviously heard you know i
feel like a lot of us
musicians and uh people of minority
groups
um you know really uh appreciate people
who represent the voiceless so
to a degree it really felt like uh like
that yeah well
on the way to oneness right there's uh
there's
always bumps in the road which is 20 20
right i mean what i mean
i feel like 2020 was an explosion of
just
that sort of energy and it's like i feel
like i heard this expression this
morning it's like um
sometimes it's one step back two steps
forward
and is that does that feel like what
2020
was you know i'm still
processing it you know a lot has
happened i mean i i
you know between like going through a
breakup dealing with family
stuff and um just trying to maintain a
semblance of normalcy
has been really crazy for all of us and
then to
add the the rise of the black pumas
to my story uh it's been
completely unreal and i gotta tell you
i'm thankful
danica that uh you know i have the team
that i have as they have been very
supportive
yeah well you had mentioned you touched
on some things that hit my
that that strike a note with me which is
like break up and
you know then i had them moving and
everything so what was
i mean to me 2020
was about like a burning down of
um anything that wasn't
that isn't going to benefit us moving
forward and
like what i mean can you tell me about
what you learned from the year i think
that
uh just like much like probably most of
us or anyone else
i think that what happens is when you
know
mother nature is kind of bucking up at
us i think that uh
um we all kind of get put in a place
where our anxieties are magnified and
people are kind of forced to deal with
themselves in their own shadows as it
pertains to their
family dynamics and business you know
relationship dynamics
um yeah it's it's been crazy to
to reconnect with self in this
retrograde period that has been
you know kovac 19 and being quarantined
amidst like civil unrest and all this
it's been it's been
absolutely crazy i i don't i don't know
i mean
is this real life is it real life i
don't know what's going on
it's wild right now that's my favorite
thing to question
is what's real like what's what's
reality
are we a simulation are we zeros and
ones what am i really looking at outside
the window what's happening in the world
am i truly creating it is there some
sort of level of
existence where it's because something
comes into my
sort of like energy field and i keep
perpetuating it in some way i don't know
i get the indication like maybe
these are like some thoughts that go on
in your head
am i most most definitely you're most
definitely not
off um i think that uh you know we all
kind of get locked into the
comfortability that is
understanding different formulas uh to
get
something that we need or to go
somewhere that we would like to
to go and and i think that in a lot of
occasions
we kind of forget we forget the the
essence
that the essence of who we are is is
quite infinite
and um i think that uh
you know a lot of us including myself
i'll admit that
you know i can be live quite selectively
you know
um in my own acceptance of what is
you know so it's it's an interesting
conversation for sure
i know i and i want to keep that going i
want i i know you're a musician but i
to me i want to get to the point where
this all kind of loops back in but i
think
this is an interesting conversation to
enter
into about you know perhaps
how you arrive where you where you do
with your music
in in all the different facets of it
whether it's the lyrics or whether it's
the
frequency of it the energy of it so i'm
gonna i'm gonna keep this
uh conversation going about sort of like
the quantum
i mean how deep does that rabbit hole
get like i i
have you always been interested in in
sort of the nature of reality
i think so to a degree i it's uh i think
the most beautiful
aspect of it is that i'll never
understand completely i'll i'll never
and
i'll never be able to conceptualize
the uh kind of said thoughts of god
right like that was
albert einstein's thing he wanted to
know the thoughts of god and i think
that
we all kind of pursue that that uh like
a sense of um
just eternal
you know miss you know that a sense of
like just
being able to like live forever i think
is you know a great
pursuit of mankind probably the plight
we all want to live forever
um but but yeah
to conclude that i feel like my process
has been
being okay with not understanding while
also
diving so deep into the the creative
process
which is also um you know my my therap
my therapy you know i started playing
music because i wasn't um
you know i needed you know kind of an
age at a younger age
when i was in high school to kind of
guide through the that angsty phase that
uh most of us go through and
um you know being given a guitar by my
youngest brother was
the greatest gift because i would just
just sit in my room and feel things i
mean i wasn't i never
necessarily think about the the actual
physicality of
oh okay here i'm gonna play piano or you
know i got my guitar and i got all these
formulas i'm going to build this and
make this it's for me it's more about
feeling into something that is there
that i may not
recognize you know at face value
and then i kind of leave it up to the
rest of uh
you know you guys humanity to to to take
what i'm reciprocating and
you know ask yourself the question is
this person being honest because if he
is
then whatever is coming from his heart
is going to touch someone else's
well this morning i was sitting and
getting ready and
having breakfast and you know into my
consciousness came this
this word or this information which is
that
and i already know this is going to
resonate based on the
short conversation we've already started
to have is that
your music is
tapping into the collective
consciousness
through its frequency
or the energy of the song and the
uh where it came from it's as if it
carries the energy
your energy from when you made it and
it's being transmitted through to all of
us and it's carrying this energy
as and we're resonating with it because
it is an
aspiration of the collective of where we
want to go and where we want to be
and the kind of energy we want to hold i
don't know
i know that sounds very like esoteric
and out there but that's what came in
this morning i wrote it down i literally
like wrote this down a piece of paper
i was like that is i feel like there is
an aspect of your music that embodies
the energy
or emotion or frequency of what the
collective
wants which is soul and emotion
and smooth beauty that's what i wrote
down
does that resonate i think that's very
beautiful danica that's that's very well
articulated
eloquently enough and i'll just i'll
add to it by uh
uh agreeing that uh i i believe that
um the joys that we experience um
to the pains that we experience um
is reflective of the next person like
your joy and your pain isn't separate
from mine and you know when i take to
you know creating and you know doing my
writing
i just try to be honest because i know
that
i know that i'm feeling what you're
feeling to some degree i can i know that
there's there's somewhat of a ripple
effect
that is danica patrick's uh process that
affects me in some way shape or form so
yeah i just try to be honest
it's it's not it's not one it's millions
number one on amazon you're number two
on itunes you're trending on twitter
you're
performing at the inauguration like this
is not just me
but it has to be me to be
everyone else essentially right because
it's the collective so you have to
you're you're sort of getting into this
aspect of each of us
and so you know i just think that it's
so it's so
interesting so it's it feels to me like
there's almost
what i heard you say it's almost like a
like a channeling of information
is that accurate sure i would say that
we're all
our own individual vessel for
what is the the collective you know
and that's and that's just it and then
any other stories that we tell ourselves
to uh you know separate us from the next
person is just
you know you you can end up in down so
many different
rabbit holes of paths to take in your
own journey so
but yeah this is i don't know i don't
have too much to say about it but
no i think and and and i do i just don't
want to you know
i don't want to preach at you here but i
i think about these things and i just
i feel i feel very lucky that i get to
do this with you first of all and
connect with anyone on a deep level you
know
especially after last year yeah
i i love these conversations i think
that
in my opinion this is the direction of
the collective
is in this more energetic space it's in
this more
sort of tapping into the energies of
things instead of sort of what we see
with our naked eyes i mean
that should have been a pretty obvious
thing in 2020 that
you know we're trying to decide what's
real and what's not real anymore and
it's it's my intuition that we're being
sort of led to this place where we're
gonna have to feel
what's real and what's not because
energy doesn't lie
and so we have to get good at being able
to to feel that and i think that people
can
feel your music and your truth and your
energy
um you had said something just a minute
ago about
um you know about this sort of about the
collective about
you know my energies your energy and
and i'm trying to where did that come
from can you get
is there more of a root of where that
awareness came from
in your journey um it
it came it comes from where it comes
from for for
all of us you know it comes from my pain
it comes from
it comes from trauma comes from my joys
my highest
you know honors and you know and just
excitement
it's it's like you said it's it's about
feeling into it yourself
that you may be a you know a suitable
conduit to
then reciprocate um you know your own
way of
making sense of what we can't tell
as real or not you know from time to
time so
um so yeah i don't know it's an
interesting that's an interesting
subject
i think that uh i can only trust
the the feelings that i have from my
experiences
as i uh co you know cohabitate
with the rest of uh the world you know
what are um if you're willing to share
what are some of those traumas that
catapulted you into this awareness
to a deeper understanding of humanity
of yourself right it starts with the
self and expands
most definitely yeah i think that uh
we have first of all we have these kinds
of conversations to
i feel to grasp you know and to to
like to grasp life and to feel some
semblance of control
of uh what's going on in your life and
so anytime
most people are out of control it's
frightening
and you know i've i've found that you
know coming from busking and
you know on the trains to you know
riding
two or three buses to get to uh the
santa monica pier from
athens california where the uh
the the state of people's existence
there
is quite um quite
it's drastically different than the
warmth
that you get around people near the
water
like no worries by the water there's
just a certain level of uh
energetic kind of uh interplay that
happens when you're like
near near a beach but
i think that for a long time
i have felt completely and utterly
out of control and the whole
the whole my whole reason my strong
reason why
for creating music is to you know have
some sort of a vehicle
to reach those inner truths and
and to reach some of those shadows that
i may not see all the time
in in my reaction to the world as it is
coming from where i come from so
i guess to specifically speak to
my process and what i've felt
um in the past in my in in my journey
um i feel like uh you know sometimes you
feel
you got to feel voiceless you know
especially you know for who i am and
what i look like where i'm at um you
know
there's a there's i feel like i've seen
a level of um prejudices and
uh indifferences uh you know
kind of directed at me and and people
around me as well like it's not just
about like
you know being responded to because uh
you know i'm black or or i'm a musician
but it's also like
busking on the street is kind of you
know you know you're at the
low end of the totem pole for uh social
kind of uh acceptance and so um
i i felt a lot in my busking days
just uh there's this sense of utter
loneliness
and when you're you know
at the end of the day and you know
someone you know
this homeless guy takes off with your
guitar you got to chase him down and you
know it's like
craziness you know it's like it's i
don't even know how to like look back
at those days and remember like
anything that was normal about you know
picking up my guitar
and taking my songs that i wrote in a
very vulnerable space
to then kind of almost cast my pearls
amongst the rest of the people right
because not every not everyone's gonna
be as nice as danica patrick and
listening to my
my uh process
you haven't seen all sides of me um
you obviously don't know how mean i used
to be in my race car when i was racing
um that's very nice of you to say you
mentioned the word vulnerability
and i think that is an aspect of
an existence whether it's through music
or whether it's through speaking or
or whatever that resonates like that
cuts through it cuts to the heart
right and i've always been really
fascinated by music and how
whether it's a speech or a song or
whatever it's like
if you're willing to go there and i've
been thinking a lot about the difference
between
um vulnerability and transparency and
transparency being something they're
ready to say
right so there might be something that's
sitting and waiting and ready to be
you want to tell people and it's out
there but you know you want to
and you're comfortable talking about it
but then
vulnerability is different vulnerability
is the stuff that you're not
sure you're ready to say it's like
sitting there but you're like i don't
know how this is going to go
i don't know how this is going to be
received i don't know if i
feel comfortable and i feel that the
it seems like a lot of the magic in in
those
in these sort of public deliveries is
his vulnerability and i'm i've always
been fascinated how you can get there
how you can
you know because i would describe myself
as someone who's working on
vulnerability although i'm
very transparent i'd say that
vulnerability is something that i need
to do a better job of
saying things that i'm not sure i'm
ready to say yet um and it's sort of
masked
by the fact that i'm very open which is
transparent and so
can you feel that difference between
like a message
that might not that that is about
transparency versus that sort of
other sort of lane of vulnerability and
and is that part like is that easy
is that the calling of an artist
and um is that part of this um these are
a lot of questions but
and is that part of like the magic
formula
of a song definitely
i think firstly i think in many ways
our uh state
uh like our state of being truly depends
on
the stories that we tell ourselves as we
experience
the externality that is you know living
in
the hood or or growing up rich and
but but without love and feeling you
know
into all of what what you're seeing
hearing and feeling coming inward
out like coming inward from outside of
yourself
and i think that uh i have
it's really actually very easy for me
it's the only way that i know how to
to be and to to to write is from a place
of
vulnerability you know i'm just this
this poor kid
who grew up in uh los angeles california
skateboarding around you know
uh and using the modality that is music
to
to tap into to my greater self
and it's really it's it's actually
really easy for me to
uh do that and in my
and and to be vulnerable i may not
always know how to
articulate um in great depth
you know for whatever whatever the
reasons are but uh yeah i
i it's easy for me to be vulnerable
actually
um well so i would then i would go to
venture to say them that really all of
your music is
in that vulnerable space think so
a couple coupled with what what kind of
muddles it
when when it comes to making music
especially on deadlines for
massive events is sometimes that that
side of the business side of it
uh tends to kind of you know
make the creative process a little bit
foggy
and and maybe maybe even in some cases
less thorough
in in the connection your your own
connectivity to yourself because you're
trying to accomplish
the packaging of this product for
whoever
you know and for the for the world so
that we can win a grammy or whatever
whatever externality that we're
kind of seeking but i've always kind of
uh
it's always kind of been enough for me
to
venture into dark dark places and
light places but and to and to feel
comfortable within myself feeling
into these things because i always had
the modality that was
music through you know my guitar and i
just
i loved feeling and hearing like wow
like this is what it sounds like when
i'm like
turned on or this is what i sound like
when
you know i'm in survival mode for
for whatever whatever the reason is
trying to make it as a
human being around so many people who
kind of uh
we all kind of have our stories that we
kind of uh we
we look to as guiding lights in our
conversing with each other so
i think that's been like my biggest
you know struggle um and you know
i feel like i i see it in like a
i don't know i think it's it's a really
big struggle to to uh traverse the
energy
that is individuals what's different
like from different walks of life with
you know who may hold
different uh uh ideologies
but as you said to conclude as you said
danica
the most beautiful thing is the thing
that i'm most thankful for
is for how universal
my my pains and joys are
how much that's reflective of how
universal
the music is for all people like i mean
for you know statistically i should not
you know be where i'm at and you know
convert conversing and
with people who i'm conversing with
because of the stories that we all tell
ourselves and and
you know we kind of being locked into
such a caged reality of the mind that
is almost perpetuating a certain
ideology about the person and so
i'm thankful that i grew up in a family
that uh
you know my grandparents were
missionaries and you know my uncle's
musician and my mom's a dancer and were
very like theatrically musically
inclined people
and you know i just i always went to the
high schools that were diversified and
i never really i never did all white
this or all blackness or whatever i was
always i was always interjected into
uh realities that involved different
people
and so for that and and then
with the aid of music for that i feel
like i've always felt like
i could go anywhere and and do
anything that i want to do and i've
proven that to myself in
in like small ways and in some big ways
as well
there's an idea that um
[Music]
it's out there right it's um that you
know
for source energy we kind of hold the
we hold the frequency of all aspects
within ourselves like you've heard like
you are the universe looking at itself
kind of thing like you
are the universe and so
that would make me think that we're not
actually
at all separate in our understanding
like
there's an aspect of myself that can
understand you and there's an aspect of
you that can understand me
because the collective consciousness of
being source energy
allows us this opportunity to hold this
aspect um i don't know do you
would you i agree that's very well put
yeah i would definitely
agree and i appreciate that perspective
because it does acknowledge
that although we you and i have
different backgrounds
it does acknowledge the fact that we
connect on such a deep level
you know it's it's you can't even
i don't know if you can even quantify
the
what we're sharing right now it's so
beautiful it's it's the coolest thing
where do you sit spiritually i'm curious
i i did you go to church growing up
i did i did i i uh uh reluctantly
my my parents my grandparents uh made me
join the the choir
well obviously you have a song you're
the songbird of our generation
hey beautiful voice i received that
thank you danica so
yeah i i grew up in church and i also
grew up
in in iraq like my uncle worked with um
uh he did like outreach with children
programs and
um just you know uh
he worked he's worked with teens a lot
and so i've i've kind of grown
up around troubled souls to to a degree
and
and to understand someone or to hold
that aspect that you just recently spoke
of
with someone from a completely different
walk of life who
you know was kind of propelled down
a path of misunderstanding
and confusion for that i
i'm very thankful because i see myself
in these individuals and
um for being able to be around them in
the first place
you know that that the idea that i'm
separate from the rest of the world
uh beca begins to kind of uh dissolve
you know a bit maybe more so than
someone who
who's always lived in one place talk to
the same people
you know less exposure to the rest of
the world
right and that that that exists
in so many places i i mean i've
experienced it i've
you know walked to the world of i lived
in england for a while i
grew up in the midwest i lived sort of
in the
south i drove nascar i've lived out in
california
like i'm in arizona now i mean i
i have seen and there are so many sort
of pockets of the world that
you know i don't i think that the
ability to run
from um run from things is becoming
much less likely and much more in in
your face
as far as accepting
all aspects of life and people and
respecting and
getting to understand it right there's
so many pockets that they don't actually
want to
like it's almost it's almost too it's
it's almost
way too much work to hold on to the
build up that is
the confusion that we've all kind of uh
experienced just in last year alone and
uh the the illness the diseases and
everything that
we've experienced the losses it's it
becomes to be
too much to hold on to
so i i you know you you see people and i
myself you know i'll drink and
you know sometimes i use firefighters to
to
to negate that you know there's an
aspect here that i may not be always
cognizant of or
seeing and uh
but i think that especially after last
year
most of us have gotten to a breaking
point where
you're either you know you're going to
drink yourself to death and commit
suicide or get a divorce or whatever it
is
or you're going to let go
of your idea of how the world
should spin around and and you know how
people
should be or how your life should look
externally
and so i think that we're all in this
like retrograde process that is
retreating
back to what is and always has been
in our own eternal peace and love that
we have access to
and you know as part of source you know
yes yeah that's beautiful
that's really beautiful what you just
said um
this process it's a house of cards right
so when you start to
break through to the foundation of
someone
which could be religion it could be you
know their
everyday life and their patterns and um
their belief system then it's it becomes
a house of cards you pull the bottom and
the whole life gets turned upside down
and i love the saying that your new life
is gonna cost your old one i mean i
don't love it and but it's just true
and so you know that can be a really
it's almost like the subconscious is
aware of this
sort of daunting gonna call it task
because once you start on the journey
it's such a ride
like the spiritual journey is such a
ride and you never wanna get off even
though
god sometimes it's just so much and it's
so
it's so painful um
but there's always lessons in it and
that to me that's why
it's called growing pains right my
my favorite uh people to look to in that
are i have some very stoic friends who
i i i sometimes question i'm like
come on bro you gotta you gotta be mad
sometimes you gotta you know you gotta
be upset sometimes you know it's
it's it's we're friends you can you can
talk to me you know about things but
i i do i do tend to uh
[Music]
you know admire those who
understand the idea
that the your spiritual journey or
whatever it is your process as a human
being
um is is always in movement
it's it's not something that you can say
no to you know i think
saying no to the journey that you're
inevitably
taking anyway um for you know
with the cho like by the by way of
choices that you're making
um it just it's just gonna make it
to me it makes it harder you see people
get
when we have like these uh i loved
learning about like how
like mind over matter and how uh
our biochemistry is affected by our
thought process and you know
as as we've experienced traumatic
experiences
you know our tissues inside hold on to
these things
and you can see people like holding on
to them like you get you know you got
just weird looking faces and all kinds
of like
from not from holding on to uh and
and not understanding that
you know living in a mindset of
abundance as opposed to a mindset of
lack is
kind of easier said than done but but
definitely key
so yeah i'm still understanding it have
you had that
sort of um spiritual house burning down
now i'll back up to say like you know
you have an issue it's coming to you
it's kind of knocking at the door and
then it pounds down you know
pounding at the door and then it breaks
it down then it comes in and terrorized
place and then finally it's like
i'm gonna burn your house down oh yeah
have you had
something in your life where you're like
so yeah i had to get to the house
burning down part
most definitely i mean as uh as
mentioned before
i i grew up in church you know i grew up
under the
the jurisdiction of my grandparents and
my mom and my uncle and
brothers and sisters and
i think that when i decide to commit to
something
i am 100 percent committed i choose my
friends
very wisely you know my friends know i
don't play
i don't play games you know and uh
because when i believe in something i
tend to believe like really hard and i
and
you know that's not to say that uh
that's not to say that like i am
unwilling
to be malleable to the degree that i'm
i'm able to accept
different ideas as part of my own
but i had to get to a place where you
know
i was balancing my relationship
with source and god
in in conjunction with what my life
looks like you know it's like well you
know
if if uh you know god is real then why
then why don't i have any money
i want money you know and or whatever it
is you know and
for a lot of people i i i don't mean to
you know
say that facetiously because you know
lack of money is kind of uh
and resources is a big deal it's a real
thing
i mean it's a real thing yeah but it's
also a mindset like you said
from the very beginning about your
perception of a situation
and as soon as you think to yourself
how much you want something it's
my understanding from an energetic
standpoint that if you want something so
badly there's also
you're carrying an equal resonance of
awareness of a lack of
definitely and and with that said
i remember growing up and being
encouraged
he said i remember one of the pastors or
my uncle
said eric i want you to start uh
thinking about what your wife is going
to be like and who she is and
and what she does and i i i would
be lying if i told if i told you right
now that i thought of danica patrick in
my head
but it is but it is a really really uh
nice reflection to you know just have a
conversation with the
intellectual person very beautiful and
talented
and you know those are part of what i
kind of
see myself kind of uh cooperating and
collaborating with so
for that i'll maintain my mindset of uh
abundance and receive it well thank you
it's very nice of you to say you're
welcome it was kind of like long-winded
but yeah oh
no i i love i love this conversation i i
it's um it's so fun for me to explore
these sort of corners of
um of the mind where
it's not always we don't always go there
and i have
you know a bunch of questions to ask you
that are so much more sort of like
linear and lateral with the you know the
world that you live in but this is one
that
to me my show is about ex sort of
planting seeds with people
and i'm not trying to make anyone think
anything
but you know you arrived at this
conversation
for some reason you're still listening
for some reason
and in this sort of journey some people
are far along on their spiritual journey
some people are beginning it
some people don't even know they're
about to begin it some people might
never
but it's implanting these seeds through
this conversation
and exposing people to this other to
these other
aspects of life these other thoughts and
experiences
and um and planting these seeds for
people so that maybe when they hear it
the second time they're like um
okay maybe this i remember hearing about
this
there's a difference between hearing
things for the first and the second time
become sort of a pattern and maybe a
sign for somebody so
i'm so grateful for you to entertain
this conversation
of sort of like depth and more more in
the
sort of energetic realm of existence
because
to me it's it's really all we are i mean
like i again going back to the nature of
reality
you know i loved interviewing neil
degrasse tyson and and going
okay so i'm pretty sure i heard that if
you combined all
humans into actual matter we're the size
of an
apple is that right he's like yep
basically so
i'm like that just has that just blows
your mind to
trying to wrap your head around what
we're really doing here
and isn't the goal to be happy like
we're all trying to figure out how to be
more peaceful how to be happier
and it's it's only in knowing more about
the nature of our reality that we can
start to figure out how to actually get
there
most definitely i think that the first
step is talking about it and
for that i'm like really thankful that
uh you know
i've found myself in in in on such a
path that
i would be talking to you about this
stuff you know it's kind of
this feels a little bit bizarre and but
but it's like uh
you know it's it's really cool too it's
like wow okay like i could have been
talking about uh the super bowl with
uh so and so over a miller light i don't
know
but um are you playing at the super bowl
now too
um i don't know i don't know
there might be something happening um
but we'll we'll see
yeah very exciting um
you know in all of these conversations
there's so much
authenticity to your music it's it's um
and i feel like from a music musical
standpoint from a musician's standpoint
when you talk about
labels and expectations and
um identifying yourself in a genre which
i think it's crazy to hear that you
loved hip-hop because you're not really
singing hip-hop
so i'm curious about that but then it
leads me to just this
sort of idea about control and i feel
like you've heard so many times with
artists how
you know there's an expectation level
and there's deadlines and then there's
sort of
staying inside of the working parameters
of your music and what's
selling and i'm just curious
what you're gonna be are you going to
maintain your creative control is that
something that ends up getting
lost because of you know money and
labels or is that really
just someone getting lost
in that sort of space where they just
end up becoming people pleasers as
opposed to and
short-term gains versus long-term of
keeping the integrity because look
your music's timeless like that's
something so
magical about it is that there's it's
there's there's like such a
um there's such a an old-school
sort of uh feel and sound but
it's it's blowing up in 2021
so yeah it's so wild i i love
i love how how uh distinctively
it's uh reflective of you know some of
the oldest american
music and and gospel and you know negro
spiritual
to you know blues and rock and roll and
as it's progressed
um what's the genre if you were to put a
genre i'm like
what do you call it i guess i guess you
would just call it
uh soul music i mean i i i don't usually
call it
it just it i'm just being sincere and
i usually don't i don't like to call it
because i don't know that uh
i don't i don't know that i'm like i'm a
soul artist i mean i'm i'm doing my best
impression
you know but you know but but keep keep
your keep your head on tight because uh
uh i i feel like you guys have given me
some time and space
to feel okay with being completely
myself you know so
that's what i'm looking forward to
mostly started there because you started
there
yeah and there's there's a warmth there
is is
is uh the point that i'm making it's
like you know it's like a coming home
you know it should i want i want the
music to feel like
the safest place for anyone and everyone
everyone's invited to the party at my
place
it does i mean i think that's that's
what's happening i don't know if i
answered your question
i don't know if i did it well i just
want to i just basically your
your fans and and and and for the
greater good
of the collective like we want to know
you're going to get to keep making your
vulnerable
real authentic sincere and maybe you
even
maybe this is the beginning of a new
category of music like there is no name
for it because
it it it can't be pinned down and
there's sort of
the thought of um you know once you name
something you restrict its potential by
naming it like as soon as you name this
a microphone it can't be anything else
as soon as you call a bird a bird it
can't be anything else so as soon as you
name your music something it can't be
anything else
and so maybe sincere is the name of your
music of the genre because it's just
whatever is sincere in the moment yeah i
mean and it's
it's just the easiest thing to do you
know i feel like the the misconception
you know in this industry and i'm sure
in many other industries you can kind of
you know relate it um is is
i think that the perception is that like
you can make
you know you can throw something
together really quick acoustic or
electronically i won't
point to a specific genre but i think
that there's uh
you know in some music some people
perceive
the music that we're hearing today is as
shallow to a degree
and i think that it's really hard to do
that
like i just i don't know how to it's
just not that fun for me
if i if i can't if i can't be
if i can't use music to you know seek
my highest self my highest truth and to
then
reciprocate that uh in service
uh to the rest of you know the people
listening and so
i don't think i don't i don't see that
ever changing
and you're right though the business
aspect of things
definitely influence you know the
you know my thought process and in a lot
of different ways which is
which is which is uh something that i'm
definitely struggling with right now
just just kind of balancing like oh wow
there's like so
so many grand opportunities that are
coming up and it's almost distracting
from
from the process you know of like just
being like
you can imagine yourself meditating in a
hall
uh to then you know have you know a a
a song playing of a bunch of buddhist
monks chanting like a
lady gaga song you know it's like it's
just it's a little
it's a little distracting you know from
i don't know for
for me it would be i don't know if
that's a that's an arbitrary example but
are you saying from a creative
standpoint are you talking about from a
performance standpoint
generally just being a
i feel like that's a good question
danica
i feel like uh i feel like it's hard to
be
it's hard to be yourself sometimes it's
hard to be myself sometimes like
unapologetically and completely me
for the the social constructs that we
all live within and under um so
my whole pursuit to anything that i do
is to
just be comfortable with myself and and
then
and and being okay if uh energetically i
may not be compatible
to some and learning learning to love
people from the distance that they
allow you to love them you know and you
know i'm not
perfect but uh but isn't that loving
that's loving through
more through sources eyes or god's eyes
or whatever you want to call it is that
you actually see behind the veil of the
mask
and you can see the true self back there
and you're like
i love you i know you're struggling and
i know you just said that to me or i
know you just
you know did that to me but like you're
doing the best you can
whether it's your family raising you and
religion being important and they're
doing the best they can whether it's my
dad yelling at me when i was a kid
racing and
you know hurting me and you know
he's doing the best he can and and so as
to me i feel like it's that you know you
know you have this beautiful ability to
be able to see behind the mask of those
people and
and um and uh i think that's really
special but
our triggers like that make us insecure
i mean those that's just called being
human those are just those aspects in
which we need to heal
and that's so human and so i think
you're so far ahead of the game and your
vulnerability
and and your and how you present and how
what you
what you're showing the world because
there's so many people that are trying
to fit into
shoot you're like i don't know there's
no genre for this so many people are
trying to fit into a box
so many people there's almost
everybody's trying to fit into the box
of their phone and figure out like okay
how can i look
perfect in this box and um
so i feel like you've done a lot of the
work i mean i'd like
i mean i would be lying to say i
wouldn't
i didn't wish that i wrote old town road
i i would be lying
you know it to say to say that i i don't
i don't care that i didn't write that
um but i think that uh
the point is especially as it pertains
to what you mentioned earlier about the
business kind of
uh acting to influence our creative
process
is that like it just it just gets a
little bit harder because
it's like i'm i'm human just like anyone
else with with uh
needs perceived needs and desires to
feed
this shell you know with
everything and all the good stuff and
whatever
uh and so i think that the more that you
get and the more that you have
the responsibility that you that we all
have to
to self becomes a little bit more heavy
um for for the the other variables at
play
um that don't have anything that
necessarily don't have anything to do
with
like what danica's about as opposed to
like
what danica's trying to sell you know
how do you have an accountability
process do you have
your own process to
check in stay checked you know
people or practices definitely
uh i like to meditate i've done the uh
the vipassana retreat it's like really
10-day retreat yeah wow yeah you should
tell people about that my friend was
talking about doing a vipassana she's
done
two already and oh it's amazing i love
talking
so i feel like probably an aspect of me
i should probably go do a vipassana
but tell people whatever is and give
them give them some insight because this
might be something that just like
somebody might hear this and be like
that's what i need have you done it
no oh my god danica i can already tell
because you're brilliant
and you're very articulate and you have
so many ideas
and everything like a lot going on i
could tell
that if you went my pages of notes i
i see you but i i would be really
curious to
to see what you were to create
after you know going through that
cleansing process if i may of just kind
of
sitting and breathing can you describe
whatever is for those who don't know
the possum is a technique i think used
started by the
buddhist practice it's pretty much just
you know mindfulness um so in in that
you know you sit sit down indian style
or however
and you allow you close your eyes and
allow your monkey mind
the task that is focusing on the breath
coming out of the nose every sensation
that you feel
from small to great and once you feel
that your mind is
sharpened and honed in on that then you
move to the
sensations fro to at the top of the head
all the way down to the soles of your
feet and
you you can come up with your own system
but as long as you're you give your
attack your mind the task to
feel a sensation at every point
of your body for about an hour
is is how long you usually sit for it's
it's just like it's scientifically
proven to uh you know help with the
brain
certain you know connectivities that i
think
go array you know or arrive
in our processes um yeah it's i mean i
wish i could
talk more about it ten day retreat
right ten days of silence first day you
get there you kind of get the rules and
the
the women are separated from the men and
we got your living in quarters they put
you up for free they
they feed you for free vegetarian food
so yeah so that was pretty much uh
my vipassana experience on the eighth
day i remember
this weight coming off of my shoulder
like you get to a place where
you've meditated long enough in the 10
day period
where you can your your
your body your mind starts to
feel more uh more biochemical reactions
and responses to
what's going on up here that it should
feel like a dissolving
like your whole body is dissolving
because there's so much movement that
happens
over you know very small integers of
time
and um i just remember a massive
release of this feeling of being
addicted to being
sad you know we feel into things
and you experience life and we don't we
don't realize that wow like we're
actually addicted to these to these
feelings that we had when
you know we our friend died or we broke
up or
you know whatever it is your body
remembers that and until you can
get in there and dissolve it oh
wow so as you said oh you know
as you said the issue you know i i heard
the issues are in the tissues but how
there's the emotions that get held in
the body and you can see that people are
still holding on to them you can sort of
see it in how they
present or you can you know these
emotions that become so strong like an
act something happens and then you
there's an emotional sort of connection
and then that chemical is now produced
and it's like somehow
even though we know it's bad for us
we're addicted just like
drugs or anything else it's like it's an
addiction
and it's really hard to break those even
if it is just a memory
right completely well said danica
this has been awesome yeah yeah well
it's clear that you do the work it's
clear that you're really present and
you're really connected with yourself
which is no mystery why the
why the music resonates so
widely and so deeply with people and i'm
so glad that
we were able to have this conversation
and that i'm so
i'm like feel so grateful for it and for
that sort of
a deeper sort of i'm going to call it
that sort of connect
the entanglement that we have with the
interview coming today and that
information about
it's just resonating with people on an
energetic level
so strongly and you know it's
really powerful and i don't want that to
be
i don't want your work to be overlooked
it's just music it's it's carrying a
greater level of effectiveness than just
pure entertainment even though it is
entertaining
well keep praying for me danica because
uh
i feel that i have a long way to go
and you know though i'm very comfortable
in the moment and
feeling into myself i'm also vulnerable
to
to other aspects of life too that that
that aren't always encouraging of such
beautiful fruit so for that if i can
just be honest you know that's
i think it's important to you know not
take too much uh credit for the
for the glory that is uh colors or
whatever
whatever beautiful thing that comes out
of one
well as one of my favorite people to
listen to for quick little 15-minute
bursts of good information
abraham hicks is that you can't get it
wrong and it's never done
hey i'll take that i have to one one
final question though where did the name
come from where did black pumas come
from
um you know we were trading a slew of
names uh via text adrian and i
i think he had just come back from
mexico on a vacation
and uh you know i thought he was crazy
because he kept sending me like cat
names
i'm like what what is what the what is
with you and cats like you
you know and so he goes yeah i've just
seen so many like amazing iconography
over there and
synchronistically so one of his friends
when he got back home sent him like a
jaguar head and so
we were we were trading names back and
forth and i noticed him being stuck on
the cat thing
so i was like all right well i mean who
knows how
how far this thing is going to go anyway
well what we can we can we can be the
the cat name uh so we settled on black
pumas because
it it felt it felt pretty cool well
maybe uh maybe you're being called to
peru
because i went to machu picchu and
there's like a
a cat head that they would call a puma
it's the puma
i feel like pumas are really present in
in peru
like jaguars are very much like i just
was in tulum
mexico for a couple weeks and like
jaguars are really popular there um
maybe maybe maybe yeah
maybe so i think i feel like you just
put it out there so i gotta go now
i gotta go maybe maybe i'll see you out
there too i
would be i'd love to go back you never
know
exactly what kind of stuff will
transpire in
in an interview and where you might go
but we were meant to have this
esoteric conversation it felt wonderful
thank you so much for that breath of
fresh air keep doing it man
i'll be paying attention peace guys
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click
on the subscribe button